yeah hello welcome to this video the
match master yeah what is this the
Queens gambit accepted him mmm we have a
great recipe there that opening is some
really not played that often and there
is no particular reason for that as
black is okay in many lines this is one
of them yeah I don't have any good
recipe against this but I'm not alone
okay so might be t7 here yeah maybe I
just grabbed the bishop hell yeah I was
thinking about this and I wasn't really
sure if this is something that I should
worry about my night on edge for is a
bit off side yeah ticking seems wrong
and he might have all kinds of tricks
there after have three yeah yes and
probably still have to do it maybe that
was wrong that move autumn okay on the
night move I can still retrieve my night
on from g2 and so i think i'm going to
go back here and see that i'm not in
this discovery all the time and if I
getting efore and we should be 3 i'm
probably all right so yeah
what we too may be too me too won't be
38 is also not doing that much maybe
better cover f3 and shore up the whole
position a little bit better I've got
good space but it looks a bit artificial
this is the setup so just you forum yeah
this is the kind of position that can
turn out to be excellent for white but
it can also blow up in your face if he
manages this is very slow the managers
to UM somehow expose the weaknesses we
had some idea with it an idea that I did
not did not spot it all okay
hmm
I can t care right 93 93 a bb5 hangs
with check my III bishop is protected by
that we at night on g2 yeah and this is
this really that great I can also repeat
REIT just retreat the bishop yeah let's
just keep this and go for queen bee
three next or possible be three
yeah nice yeah man I for he will know
night take still queen bee three and so
then I probably have should go go for a
for attacking structure here immediately
and why is the smoking I mean this is
the double attack right
hmm they're just win one win apiece yeah
it's strange
yeah I lose pieces drop off it's done
it's still right that's seen by dr none
ok i think i can i take here first
there's no way he's going to escape with
this naughty anyway black resign yeah
yeah nite xb2 was just suicidal really
even though I believe black is under
very under some pressure already okay
yeah they answered find something but
we'll we'll see the opening probably
this is wrong here the sense is wrong
and I teach for I don't know it felt
somewhat awkward okay of three and
they're a couple of interesting
possibilities now he also could have
gone here to which am probably retreat
and then 94 gets interesting what this
one even poor weird stuff and he went
down okay drop back and this and yeah I
don't know I kind of like it all right
if I can consolidate this will be great
but yeah you know his his pieces are he
doesn't have any pawns in the center and
if I expand and can bolster the center
he would just be in bad shape because he
has no central control whatsoever the
question is can you get concrete play
against my center this is given by the
engine this kind of thing with about
equal play yeah yeah I see some ideas
for black hair c5 hand and whites
position i mean i've got some some holes
of this position so it's not easy to
play
at that feels a bit better than this I
mean here here I should probably cancel
and prevent Bishop b5 but I didn't
really understand that this whilst idea
yeah this is not good I could have taken
it Queenie for oh my god when I it
wasn't exactly difficult and I did
didn't really pay any attention here
yeah this is what what the engine gives
and it's kind of difficult to avoid the
Babbage sure I care and now it's ease
away this one check yeah the computer
gives the peace seconds the night cannot
be saved and this position is entirely
entirely messy now I had no idea what
this is engines has slight edge for
white whether it's very weird very be
itself ok this ok could have played
queen bee three I know again you should
go 92 and after this you just do this
yeah I should have taken on c4 earlier
just grabbing the piece it would have
been better ok thanks for watching